- Alright so real quick,
I have to catch a plane.
And I have like 10 minutes which means
all of you in line are fucked.
(audience laughs)
(hip hop music)
So the current state of entrepreneurship
is in an interesting spot.
I think it's an amazing time
at the same token, an
awkward time for me because
I'm really fearful.
Like, I'm not about entrepreneurship.
I'm about all of you
deploying self-awareness
and figuring yourself out,
because that is always
going to be the path
that gets you to a happy place quickest.
This pedestal that
entrepreneurship is on right now
is weirdly dangerous,
because it's making a lot
of people start businesses
that ultimately won't be successful
and actually can put them
in a pretty tough spot.
So, my ambition here is not for all of you
to go home and start your own business.
My ambition is for all
of you to understand
why I'm so happy
and it's because I figured myself out
at a young age on the back of DNA,
ridiculously good parenting and
circumstance of my environment.
And that's what this is all about.
What entrepreneurship's about
is putting yourself in
a position to succeed.
I think my strengths,
which have created this narrative,
are I have really good natural
intuition and understanding
of human behavior.
So, I think that I've
understood consumer behavior
and where it's going and the internet.
I think I'm running a marathon
so I'm extremely patient,
which I think is a huge factor.
I think that my work ethic,
my actions match my ambition.
And I would say probably
my lack of fear of failing.
I think it's more
important to learn and fail
than to always be right,
mainly on the back of not worrying
about what other people think.
I think those are some
of the core ingredients
that have really helped me.
Right?
And I think the ultimate
way to put yourself
in a position to succeed
is to deploy self-awareness, so
as fun as this is gonna
sound and as hyped up
as we all are,
this is a ridiculous vibe
and a beautiful setting
and the energy is off the charts,
I really really want to set the tone and
bring it down a notch to practicality
because I want you to win.
And winning comes at a
million different forms,
but it starts with being happy.
And you will always lose when
you try to force something.
And so again, back to being self-aware,
you need to know yourself.
Do you love getting punched in the face?
Do you have the stomach for it?
And the truth is,
it's not cool, it feels cool right now,
but it's not cool, it's
just a personality trait.
What up, Vlog?
Just landed in Tampa, a
little in and out trip for
Iris and I.
It is 2:40pm.
We'll be back here at the
airport at like 7 or 8.
So, a quick little flight, but
something that's emerged in the
last three or four days for me
that I'm gonna start building on top of
and I want to interrupt
these regularly scheduled
programs of the vlog and
rant to you a little bit.
It's about kindness.
It has become very apparent to me
as I continue to dissect
why the fuck is this shit working for me
and how do I get it to work for you?
Kindness is foundational for me.
It is absolutely a core tenant,
and it delivers unbelievable
dividends in business
but more importantly, in life.
I don't know why winning in business
or being an alpha
or trying to make something happen
I'll be right with you, just
giving my rant on kindness!
Is not associated with kindness enough
and I just
am desperate for everybody watching this
to start understanding
how much kindness is
part of this equation?
It just works, it feels good,
it may not come natural to you,
but you need to dissect
it and understand it,
and more importantly if you have it,
especially if you're a tough dude,
you need to triple fuckin' down on it.
'Cause it works,
period.
End of story.
Let's go.
This is Iris.
- Hello.
- Nice to meet you, Iris, I'm Susan.
- [Gary] Let's go!
- [Iris] Nice to meet you.
- [Susan] Nice to meet you.
(light reflective music)
- [Man] Can you tell me about your
strategy, you posted a video a while ago
and right now we're
going through the whole
recruitment phase for companies
and stuff like that.
But I already know for a long time now
that I just want to do my own thing.
At that same time, you have this pressure
and this stigma that you
have to go out and get a job.
- [Gary] From who?
- From your parents and from society.
- Society doesn't have a
face, so that should be
easy to navigate.
- It's also the time management.
Should I invest a lot of
time in my side hustles,
but I'm also doing stuff for school
- Let me give you something that
really fuckin' matters.
It actually doesn't matter what you do
in all of your 20's.
You have too much time to
correct it in your 30's.
If you actually understood that
it doesn't fuckin' matter,
there is no right or wrong answer,
everything gets real fuckin' easy.
- [Man] I appreciate that.
- I mean that!
I'm not saying it to be like,
waahh!
I'm saying it because
you have fuckin' unlimited
you have unlimited time!
- Sometimes it doesn't
feel that way, though.
- No, bro,
it doesn't feel that way
because you're letting
other voices into your head.
You value other people's
opinions more than
you value your own.
And that's 99 percent of people,
that's not like, you suck,
that's what you have to
start thinking about.
Because when you're 87,
you're gonna be pissed.
'Cause then you don't have time.
Now you have the best asset.
With everything I've got,
I would trade with you
three fuckers right now.
I'm being dead fuckin' serious.
For everything I've got,
I'll take the 22 years back.
Time's the fuckin' asset, bro.
You believe it?
- I believe it, and this
is another question I have
because it's relevant to time.
How do you optimize
your time when it comes
to task of what you're doing it for?
- Well first of all,
when you have time as your asset,
you shouldn't over-stress optimizing it
which is why I'm like,
fuck up in your 20's,
because that's your biggest asset.
The leverage for you have its time.
To me, it's kind of like,
I talk a lot about macro and micro.
That's like doing things
in parallel, right?
So every day, I go hard.
But at the highest level I'm patient.
So I'm much more worried about you
dicking around from 7am to midnight today
but not doing behavior
that worries about it
at the macro.
So I'm more worried about
you watching an hour
of dumb TV.
First of all, everything
has to map your ambitions.
So first of all what
the fuck are you up to?
Because if you want to be wealthy
and live a good quality life,
it actually doesn't take that much work or
making $200,000 a year is an unbelievably
high quality of life.
The problem is, everybody now is
thinking in like, millions and hundreds
everybody thinks they're
gonna build these huge things.
- Create value.
- If you want to create value,
you can be done right now.
Just fuckin' ask every
person what they need.
- Meaningful value not just to me,
but to masses.
- Well then, if you want masses,
if you want to really impact,
what I'm up to has been fuckin'
15 hours a day for 22 years in a row
giving up all sorts of
shit, leisure and fun.
It's just about understanding,
it's self-awareness
but the biggest thing
is putting over pressure in the short term
is a bad fuckin' move.
It's a bad move.
It leads to short term behavior.
You end up doing short term decisions.
There's people that left VaynerMedia
for $3,000 dollar more in salary
because they wanted to
move out of their place.
They fucked up.
- I've been following you for a long time.
- So
- At least three years
- If that's the case, take the one
I have the most heart for
which is being patient.
Be smart.
Of course your parents
have points of view.
Of course you want to see how
you size up to your homies.
But,
I look
compared to my homies in my 20's
I was a loser.
I worked in my dad's liquor store.
That's my truth.
- [Female] I think
that's the biggest thing
at UF,
we see so many people
especially within in the business school
that are already killin' it,
and we're just like
- "Killing it".
"Killing it".
Like, what's "killing it"?
- They don't know shit about business.
- Yeah.
They're just going after
the big, best internships.
- If he was like,
if he was like, yo!
I got an internship at Facebook,
I'd be like, cool.
I don't know, like, what?
- [Female] Yeah.
- [Male] If I got a sales internship,
though, that would be different.
- It might make your mom proud.
Maybe, for that kid.
- [Female] It's not making you happy.
- By the way, maybe it does!
But that's it.
It's gotta be binary.
- [Host] Tampa, what is up?
(crowd cheers)
- [Gary] If I could use
the attention right now
to say one thing.
Please deploy self-awareness.
You don't have to be an entrepreneur.
You don't have to be anything, actually.
What you need to try to
do with all your might
is go inside your head and understand
who you are,
and not apologize for it,
and that really matters to me.
I just want to thank you guys so much
for all the good vibes.
I hope you come over and check out
the talk I'm about to give.
But I actually weirdly
rather you go back home
and fuckin' hustle on your own shit.
(crowd cheers, applauds)
Vlog!
We gotta go back episodes.
The fuckin' O.G. CFO of VaynerMedia
Scotty the fuckin' CFO the best.
So good to see you.
Lives down here now.
(laughs)
So good to see you, man.
- Good to see you.
- [Gary] Thank you so much.
No it's really real.
- [May] I'm a little sick so I'm gonna
give you hand sanitizer.
- Okay, no worries.
Hi.
- This is
she's part of the Chinese team.
- How are you?
(laughs)
- Good.
- Such a pleasure.
Thank you so much.
For real, for real.
- Thanks for coming down.
- But it's been really,
you're really helping.
- Thanks, boss.
- You're making an impact.
- Thank you.
And I'm just gonna go and
push this in, and can you
sign three books for me
for the Chinese team?
- 100 percent.
- And I'm gonna
send it to China.
- You got it.
- Alright, so
you're gonna be meeting
with YChina on March 19th?
- Yes.
- And they are a digital company that goes
that spreads messages about
what foreigners feel like
living in China.
- Yes.
- So Raz's team and his content producers
and audience has
a few questions for you.
The first question is,
why do you want to
enter the Chinese market
when you already have
such a huge following
on the Western market?
- Because my ambition is great.
The truth is, I have very big ambitions.
And in my lifetime it will be the
number one global market in the world.
It is the number one
global market in the world.
That's hard for Americans
who have had that throne
for a long time but
there are so many people
that I want to reach.
And the thought of not
being in mainland China
is just unacceptable.
- Okay.
Thank you.
- [Female] Gary, do you want
to say something to vlog?
- Yep.
About to give a speech
and that's all I have to say.
- [Female] Okay.
(audience cheering)
- [Gary] What up?
What up, Tampa?
(audience cheering)
♪ ("Tha Crossroads" by
Bone thugs-n-harmony) ♪
- Thank you.
Bone thugs, baby.
Bone thugs.
- [Audience] Gary!
Gary!
- [Gary] Guys
Guys, you're freakin' out the people
that don't know me.
(audience laughs)
- [Audience Member] Who doesn't know you?
- Here's what's up.
This internet thing?
It's real.
And the reason I go there,
I need you guys all to
listen very carefully.
Everybody, including me,
is underestimating how big
this internet thing is.
We got so lucky and we're
also a little bit screwed.
A lot of you in 30, 40, 50 years
are gonna look back at this
year and be like, fuck.
How good we had it.
I didn't get it.
And I'll tell you what I mean by that.
The reason I was able to
build my dad's business
from a three to a 60
million dollar business
like that was because of the internet.
I would have done it.
I would have had 15 liquor stores,
But it wouldn't have been done that way,
and definitely not at that speed.
This thing is so
guys, this is a more powerful computer
in your pocket right now
than President Reagan had
running the fuckin' free world.
Everything's about distribution
and what you put in it.
Do you know how crazy it would be
to wake up tomorrow and
not have the internet?
You'd just sit.
(audience laughs)
You wouldn't know what to do.
This is now where we live.
This
is not secondary
to this.
You may not like it,
you may think it's weird,
but it's the truth.
And it will play out,
and guess what?
A lot of things have
happened to the human race.
We struggle in putting
things into context.
Because you take for
granted what you have.
- [Audience Member] I really like the idea
that documenting the process
- [Gary] Huge.
- Yeah
- Bro, could you imagine,
how many people here vlogging?
(audience cheers)
- [Audience Member] Every damn day, baby!
- [Gary] Let's go!
Yeah baby!
Could you imagine if we were lucky enough
that vlogging has been around for 50 years
and we could have seen all the people
that we think are incredible,
just see their process
of coming up the game?
More importantly, back to every damn day,
my man, whether you make it or you don't,
the fact that your great great grandkids
are gonna be able to watch that film
is unbelievable.
It's
I didn't get to know either
one of my grandfathers,
they both died,
right?
Before I got to know them.
You know how cool it would be to have
all that film on them?
So, you might be thinking about vlogging
as narcissistic and
somebody's being a charlatan.
You're fuckin' short sighted.
If you're not vlogging,
you're taking something very special away
from your future family.
(audience applauds)
Tampa!
Thank you so much!
(audience cheers)
- [Audience Member] Can you
take a picture with me, Gary?
- Yeah, let's do it.
- [Audience] Gary!
Gary, please!
Right here!
Gary, right here, please!
Thank you!
- [Man] Okay Gary,
good luck!
- [Gary] Thanks,
you're so nice, bye guys, thank you.
- [Man] Thank you.
- [Gary] Awesome, bye guys.
Iris!
Guys, I gotta bounce.
- [Man] Gotta back up,
gotta back up, guys.
Excuse me, excuse me.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- [Man] Gotta go, gotta go, guys.
Got it.
See ya!
Bye, guys!
Thank you, bye bye.
- [Female] Love you, Gary.
- One life.
Do something about it.
Thank you.
(laughs)